okay I was on the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum this morning you
can find it at david pakman.com slash
read it I found some very very
interesting discussion some of which I
will tell you about right now including
a discussion about Sean Spicer at the
Emmys now I'm going to address this
tomorrow on the program I think that
Sean Spicer being invited to the Emmys
to poke fun at himself is actually very
very dangerous because it normalizes
what was hugely damaging lie after lie
after deception from Spicer during his
tenure as press secretary so I know
people are loving it Pat but I have no
interest in that kind of nonsense do you
think it matters at all that he was more
of a puppet as the White House press
secretary rather than you know like the
secretary defense or Health and Human
Services and actually making the
decisions on the ground you could
certainly make that case I think if it
matters it matters marginally I don't
think it sort of alleviates the blame
that he was a hugely destructive force
for really for the country yes also on
our reddit discussion forum a major
discussion nearly a hundred comments at
this point about my interview earlier
this week with fired Google employee
James d'amour I will not I'm not gonna
read over 60 comments to you but I would
encourage you to check out this
conversation at david pakman.com slash
read it and participate if you like also
on our reddit discussion discussion
forum the news that just after our
interview james d'amore tweeted that the
you must one must recognize the positive
aspects even of groups like the KKK and
neo-nazis which was an interesting thing
to tweet and a lot of people saying it's
too bad he didn't tweet that before the
interview David because that would have
been an interesting thing to discuss and
lastly from our reddit discussion forum
clarifying the link between hurricanes
and climate change yeah we've talked
about the link between hurricanes and
climate change before and there's a
really interesting post at david
pakman.com slash read it's sort of going
into more detail about the ways in which
climate change and hurricanes can be
linked so check that out participate
over 4,000 of our viewers and listeners
now at david pakman.com slash read it